[Music]
in Kiev slaps news clear slaps submitted
by butterfly doors oh cool that's what
you got got kind of alright that swings
they're called doors a Russian city
hosts a painful face slapping
championship oh no you did what is this
dude so like a couple years ago I've
been noticing like this I don't say
uprise but there's these videos of these
dudes doing slapping competitions where
you literally go slap for [ __ ] slap
full force and you have to put your
hands on the table
you can't move away you have to take it
ah people get knocked wait don't I got
that thing that they hold or is that
nothing else any the mother are much
easier to get knocked down yeah so like
you've been seeing these dudes getting
knocked the [ __ ] out like any slap full
force it's crazy
goes first will win then if you miss
like let's say you miss and you get all
finger versus the other person can come
and hit all palm and bang oh this
competition has rules and that's one of
them is it could only be fingers good oh
thank god can't harm the person another
rule is that you can't aim for the
temple the irony oh that's worth it how
might people want to get concussions
from this and in order to win you have
to wait till like you're trying to knock
the person out but if the person doesn't
doesn't get knocked out within three
slaps then a judge comes in well you're
trying to knock them out with fingers
yes anybody hit the temple how do they
not from the jaw the jaw just hurts so
much there's a there's an area here that
if you if you hit they'll knock out yeah
it's a little button watch like this on
your jaw because there's a nerve and
good for your brain sake already yeah
is it because a nerve or something like
there's a resin knock there's like good
that's why you say oh he has a strong
chin or whatever they don't get knocked
out is cuz this area you know there's
supposed to be a point somewhere huh
people get knocked out do those come to
fights like this
it's funny okay so I'm gonna show you
guys this video clip oh my god sounds
like it's brewed off oh my god dude that
big there's no [ __ ] that
there's no wait no wait there's also no
drug testing apparently almost moon
blanch daddy flinched him move
Oh dad will took it like a man
that Paul McGann
ready spaces oh my god they all
instantly get red
Oh see there's no weight class yeah some
people just have some thick-ass fingers
- man damn look I'll read their faces oh
we feel that blood on his hands
don't worried I am made for this [ __ ] I
thought what I'm just getting started I
put it in later
[ __ ] swollen do any do with a mullet
like that he's ready to take pain dude
that makes his teeth cut up in the
inside of his mouth you guys are [ __ ]
nuts dude if I did that competition did
and the prize was really big I gotta rip
out all my teeth first could already
imagine David the first slap oh dude I
was screaming right before we did it
here huh I would just take him out
scream along the way oh that shit's so
crazy yeah like there was this one that
got me tonight though did you ever do
that on double-oh-seven goal tonight and
in 64 the Slammers old lady just go
around when we had the [ __ ] big gummy
bear and gummy worm and we were smacking
it yourself that was [ __ ] surprisingly
strike oh my god yeah we thought it was
fun
no we just did it for fun and we're just
like let's do something stupid this was
so stupid I remember he had that worm he
goes you want to see what it feels like
I said no and he still hit me with it we
weren't even we were just kind of
swinging it so the momentum would just
smack you in the face we didn't we
didn't swing it as hard as possible we
just kind of whose just ripped it also
just like me and Steve in bed you going
stapling yeah oh yeah you you're gonna
handle that like a champ
got it you get dick slap all the time
it's just a hobby at this point that
[ __ ] looks so crazy you know it's like
so brutal to me that got me hype yeah
you want to do it no I mean we're just
coming hype girls are brutal they are
brutal nails uh no nails [ __ ] moaning I
think girls might be better at it kind
of Wow because we have a lot of
yeah I feel like the guys do this to get
away from their wives sure no I hate
like I've never done it in person but
I've only fought in my dreams Oh every
time I can just never I can never get it
satisfy it out you know what I mean like
but in dreams like this though trying to
slam doors and it's like not making
noise Oh
like that's why I end up in my dreams I
end up resorting to my nails cuz I'm
like I need to hurt this person somehow
and this isn't working and then they
crumpled into a ball you ever slap
somebody it's very very satisfying
no that's oh I did once but I was just
too angry to feel satisfied yeah because
it feels really good because a slap is
very demeaning towards the other person
because it's not a punch in the face
and then you guys have to deal with the
fact that they just got slapped it
doesn't hurt you like a punch hurts yeah
like right upside the head if you school
ah shut the [ __ ] up oh oh that's part of
boot camp culture it's called a hooking
each other up it's all I couldn't when
we're all sitting there and like a
classroom we're on the range and if
anyone starts knock its knocking out
like the drill instructor hey someone
hook them up but in a much meaner
talking then people I think they're so
repressed they have so much aggression
they just start taking it out on each
other but it's really good motivation
because then I would like I'm always
just trying to stay away
gah let's see how hard everyone slapping
each other my claw there's more inhale
art I'm not gonna Fossum I'll give
anyone the the pleasure and the
privilege to smack in my head they smack
you ever know hit or fall asleep
you just didn't sleep their head would
break you got a big ass don't when we're
in like in classes and stuff done today
than the day
yeah thick ass neck - so slight body
hook up quad up and we're good now that
boot Kent does 132 oh but your head was
always big yeah he's so funny somebody
hooks you up we don't want to start we
can't do it
like I [ __ ] dare you help me I'm
right now [ __ ] I pay people I'm
sleeping yep [ __ ] right there crazy
I feel like this started off as a
drinking game oh yeah it's Russia
Russian drinking take after their drugs
like what do you do after you're done
okay
I bet you I can slap you and knock you
out no cuz that birthday hits dude
birthday hits work terrible man I hated
birthday oh I forgot about those there
should be an age limit like you can't do
birthday hits after like the age of 10
yeah they hit you after high school oh
yeah we always did birthday kitchen
I'll whip up to like 18 and 20 you what
you would get hit by whoo yeah like like
your friends they stay like spank you
you're like you go through the line or
whatever mine was so let my always
gentle they were like doing [ __ ]
birthday hits with a 99 year old she's
getting jumped at that point it's like
the one oh [ __ ] what's that movie don't
be a menace I'll kick you juice in the
hood thank grandma Nicky box oh yeah
yeah I remember the movie I don't
remember that what I remember them
grandmas in church break that having a
break battle though Palestine do we have
a problem with nuclear bombers [ __ ] yeah
this to me is like way more brutal the
enemy or King what do they win you can't
run hard yeah there's no sale there's no
strategy there's no like this there's
what I like about MMA and kickboxing is
there a strategy and they're its
competitors there's two athletes playing
chess oh yeah this is a chess a dollar
so they make a strategy anime the
problem is there probably is but it's
you just sit there and take it you know
there's no defense that's theme there's
no D can't like guys were flinching but
that's automatic loss right just take it
and I wonder what happens like these
guys there's really no prize to it there
is a price what is it it's three thirty
thousand rubles which is about four ten
dollars
that is not a lot of money and then on
top of that yeah that was a big-ass
crowd if you really think about it like
what are these guys really doing it for
like I don't think this is gonna impress
anybody but you're not gonna walk up to
a [ __ ] girl at a bar today you know
what I did today you don't know that
it's Russia
oh maybe huh she's like you know
Facebook champion lets me all the girls
are talking about a mom did you see Egor
do you want the competition I'd rather
be this championed and that one Olympic
sport on skates anybody top a
shuffleboard whatever yeah it's they
[ __ ] scratch the ice and look that up
recently [ __ ] was that called it's not
shuffleboard
it's not it's called churning or ice
picking no Justin this one's at least
like there's some like all this guy can
have a huge pain tolerance and has
apparently that I'm like I don't know
what that tells me about you I like
pointless accompany you're just bored if
all these games are from humans be bored
like how far can you throw a stick that
shows like okay this guy has this much
ability right right like what's the
skill for this yeah what's this gonna
pop all I could shovel your driver
really well marry that dude if I was in
a snowy place that's who could shovel
this driveway who could smell the worst
[ __ ] and still stay in the I guess stay
alive smell a piece of [ __ ] straight to
the nose probably yeah so this is a big
thing in Russia like people are I mean
it was a [ __ ] ton of people there well
this is a particular city that I'm not
going to try to pronounce they aren't
hosting this country's first ever
amateur laughing championship this thing
might blow up cuz it's so easy to
understand you know you don't need I
guess
just presents itself the way it is if a
Chinese dick kicking competition we got
that [ __ ] dude if that happens like I
could kind of see that like like guys
will all over the world make up weird
[ __ ] competitions all that it's like
that movie idiocracy yeah they all watch
the i'll my balls show
getting hit in the balls oh that's like
now with the freaking compilations of
fails everyone's like getting hit in the
balls
oh I really do like those
[Music]